Iranians have said that their goal is to
spike the price of oil to $200 a barrel.
If Trump were to leave the Middle East,
basically the American empire would
collapse. It's very risky to use
military force to resolve an economic
issue.
>> It isn't enough to remind everybody that
you have a big military. You actually
have to get control of Iran.
>> This is a war that is looking for a
purpose and a strategy. The Marine
Expeditionary Force that is going to
Iran is the same force that went into
Vietnam. Like 5 years later, you're at
500,000 American soldiers. So, you can
make argument like a lot of the issues
in America come from the fact that the
baby boomers are a selfish,
materialistic, and self-absorbed
generation that refuse to surrender
power.
>> So, who are going to be the winners and
who are going to be the losers in this?
Trump in America, they continue to
[music] underestimate the resilience and
resolve of the Iranians.
>> If you had to advise the US, what would
you tell them if they actually wanted to
either get out of the war with the least
amount of damage or actually win? What
what is the play here? So a lot of the
problem is that if you look at Empire
St. Klein, they're no longer capable of
Shuji planning uh because there's a
leave um and toxic combination of hubris
and desperation. And so they so
Washington DC has become an insular
bubble, right? And if you just look at
these press conferences where reporters
are like, "Hey, Mrs. Trump, what's the
plan here?" And then Trump's like, "Shut
up, man. I'm going to put you in jail.
In fact, I'm going to pass a law that
says if you criticize us in the war,
we're going to put you all in jail,
right? Or we're going to shoot you to
death, right? That's how empires behave.
And so at this stage where empires are
in decline and they are and the
leadership is unwilling to emit any uh
possibility of defeat um and they're
just trying to force everyone to
uh repeat talking points, right? So
Peter Hexav in his press conferences is
just saying like you know the problem
with you guys is you don't talk about
the good things. All you talk about is
the bad things. Stop talking about the
bad things. You just focus on the good
things and we're then we're good. Okay.
And what what he doesn't recognize is
like uh I'm sorry but like the war's
going bad. You need to hear it and they
absolutely refuse to hear it. Okay. So
why am decline is they become so
arrogant and so insular that they refuse
to consider the possibility of defeat.
so that they always double down and I
don't know how you resolve this issue.
>> Yeah, it uh it isn't going to be easy.
That is for sure. So, okay, if we don't
know how to do it well, what is your
prediction for how it's actually going
to play out? Is this a uh Trump declares
victory, leaves it in, chaos, comes
home, or is this Trump gets sucked in
because Israel, Saudi Arabia, uh they
want a ground war. They want this
protracted thing to play out so that
they can basically jockey for power in
the Middle East. Um, which of those two
scenarios is more likely in your view?
>> Right now there's a talk of war. So it's
almost almost impossible for us to
ascertain who's winning this war because
the Israelis and Americans are doing
tremendous damage to Iran. The Iranians
are fighting back as well. So we can't
actually ascertain who's actually
winning this this war. But if you just
look at historical examples, if you just
look at grain theory, then the then the
idea is the Americans are stuck where
they are and they can only double down
because if they ever quit, right, it's
not cost fallacy. It's it's like you go
to the casino and you're losing
$100,000.
Uh if you quit now, you'll always lose
that money. So you keep on gambling.
Okay. So unfortunately what Gain third
suggests is that Trump's just going to
double down and and so I think what he's
going to do is he's going to take Car
Island. Um and he'll do it very easily
and then he'll want to secure the the
coast as well. And so you have mission
creep and unfortunately he's being egged
on by both Israel and the GCC because
Israel clearly wants this war to
escalate. The GCC wants to remove the
Iranian threat as soon as possible
because they see the amount of damage
that the Iranians can do to the GCC. So
Dubai, if nothing changes, uh Dubai will
just cease to exist because for because
Dubai is just based on uh the perception
that is a safe tax haven, right? But if
Iran can just rain drones on Dubai
uncontested, then no one's going to put
their money in Dubai. So for Dubai to
continue to thrive, it needs to destroy
Iran and move remove that threat from
the Middle East. So unfortunately um the
way that things are structured suggests
that this war can only escalate and not
actually um um move towards a ceasefire.
All right. The official story is that
this is a war to stop Iran from going
nuclear, but the framework that you've
been working off that allowed you to
predict this war nearly 2 years ago
suggests the structural forces that are
actually driving it are deeper than
that. If the war in Iran is just a
symptom, what is the actual sickness?
So, we know the cause is not uh Iran's
nuclear program because a few hours
before the Israelis um struck Tran and
killed the alatollah, the Omena foreign
minister went on TV and said that the
Iranians had agreed had already agreed
to zero um uranium enrichment even for
civil purposes which was before a red
line. So we know that the um nuclear
program is not the real cause and in
fact Trump has yet to articulate
um a good reason for why this war start
started in the first place. uh now that
the reason the administration is
articulating to the public is that well
the Israelis were going to strike first
and if that would have happened the
Iranians would have struck back at both
the Israelis and the Americans and
therefore the Americans had to preempt
um the Iranians and that's why the
Americans went in with the Israelis. Um,
so this is a war that is looking for a
purpose and a strategy.
And maybe 100 years from now, historians
will still argue over why this war
started in the first place. So um, let's
go over some possibilities.
So the first possibility is that this
war had to happen. Um, and the reason
why is the nature of the American
Empire. The American Empire um its power
rests mainly on its ability to control
maritime trade. It's able to control key
uh maritime choke points like the
straight of like like the strait of
Malaka, the straight of Humus, the
straight of Jialter.
And the great fear is that the Eurasian
caret would unify under great power. And
so in the beginning of the 20th century
there was a British strategist named
Mckender Mckender and he argued that the
greatest threat to British the to the
British Empire was um the rise of
Eurasian power whether it be the Ottoman
Empire whether it be the French uh the
Germans or the Russians because if that
power to arise that power would unify
both Europe and Asia and connect the
entire Asian clinet.
through railways and then and then
absorb the Middle East and Africa and
Southeast Asia into a continental
trading block that would negate the
naval power of the British Empire. And
the British Empire only had naval power.
It didn't have the population to sustain
a land army. We saw that um in World War
I and World War II. So the entire
strategy of the British was to create as
much to cause as much discontent and
chaos in Eurasia as possible and it and
if a great power were to arise to
basically go to war against that that
that power. So we first saw the strategy
play out during the the uh Napoleonic
wars when Napoleon basically unified
Europe and then what what Britain did
was fined seven wars seven wars against
against Napoleon. They lost six and they
won the and they won the seventh. Do do
you think that the Brits at that point
saw that as an existential threat and
that's why they were going that hard?
>> Yes. Um they did um because um Napoleon
wanted to institute something called the
continental system. So basically just
blockade um England because remember
Britain is a resource poor island. So
they were blocked off from the European
continent and if um Napoleon was able to
embargo them then they would have um
starved basically. There there's also
another issue in that um there are two
main sources of British imperial power.
The first of course is the Royal Navy.
The second which is actually more
important is the Bank of England.
>> And so the Bank of England was chartered
in 1688. Um so sorry 1694. 1680 was the
boys revolution. The glorious revolution
is important because that's when
basically the Dutch Republic merged with
the um British Empire. Uh and and the
merger happened because the um one of
the um uh Dutch princes William Orange
went over to England to become their
king, something called the Glorious
Revolution. And when they uh when that
happened, when the Dutch aristocracy
went over to England, they also brought
with them their capital and their
wealth.
>> And so they set the Bank of England um
as a private bank that would serve uh
British monarchal interests. So, so
previously before
um if you're a merchant, you lent money
to a king to fight his wars. The problem
with that is that well the king could
die or the king could lose the war or
the king um could just reneg on his
promise and said you know what I'm the
king you can't do anything about me so
screw off. Okay. So there was a lot of
risk involved in lending money to a um a
king. Now the great innovation of the
bank of England is that you no longer
let money to a king you give that money
to the parliament the nation state. So
when you do that then everyone in the
nation uh the including the children the
grandchildren are now obligated to pay
you back. Okay. And in America um this
became the Federal Reserve system. Um um
so so in other words all this wealth in
um Europe that was looking for stability
all went to England including the Dutch
Republic but also including the
Hapsburgs including the the the Catholic
um church and so that allowed England
infinite financing for wars. So even
though um it could not uh produce a land
army, it could give you the financing to
fight Napoleon. And that and that's what
led to the seven Napoleonic wars. And
and but but the problem with this is
that once you start to fight a war, you
have to keep on fighting because you if
you stop if you lost then you lose all
your money, right? So it's almost like a
Ponzi scheme. And so that's what led to
the Napoleonic wars. And again in the
seventh se seventh war Britain won was
was able to force an indemnity onto the
French um and that saved the um the
British system. Um so after the French
came the Russians which led to the
Russian great g which led something
called the great gain between Britain
and Russia in Central Asia
>> but with the same idea they're trying to
stop them from forming this heartland
alliance so that they can do trade via
trains.
>> That's exactly correct.
>> We'll get back to the show in just a
second but first let's talk about gold.
Gold is the right asset these days but
most people are using it wrong. They buy
it, hold it, and then wait for the price
to go up. But that price is still
denominated in dollars. So, you haven't
actually escaped the system. You're
still playing by its rules. That's the
shift Monetary Metals helps make
possible. They've built a way for your
gold to earn yield, paid not in dollars,
but in more physical gold, up to 4% per
year. More ounces, compounding in hard
money. every single month. You're
growing the quantity of the hardest
asset on Earth and storage and insurance
are included. So, there's no hidden fees
that are going to eat away at your
yield. Most people are passively
absorbing inflation. This is exactly how
you actively compound your weight out of
that. [music] Click the link in the show
notes or visit
monetary-medals.com/impact
to [music] learn more. This is a paid
advertisement. And now let's get back to
the show. Yeah, I want to keep beating
this point for people because this is
one of the more brilliant ideas that I
had never heard of before that you
brought forward. I'm constantly trying
to get people to understand what's going
on in Iran through the lens of
economics. And I don't know if this is
going to be a point of agreement between
us or a point of contention because I
know we're going to get into the
religious element of it with your thesis
on esquetology. We we'll get there in a
second. But um this idea that there have
been all these attempts to get people um
that that multiple different empires
have tried to unify that heartland that
you're talking about across Europe that
would essentially go from Eastern Europe
all the way to uh the Middle East and
because I had often wondered you hear a
lot that you know the US patrols the
seas that England did it before them and
I was always like how with boats that
can't go on land how exactly are you
controlling this large empire via the
sea. And this is the first way where
I've heard somebody really dive into,
well, if if you force commerce onto the
water, you actively stop it from going
on land now, you get these few choke
points. And if you can control those
choke points, you control the economics.
And if you control the economics, you
basically control the world. And I have
had a shockingly difficult time getting
people to view this war through the lens
of economics. Now I know you're just
starting here and you have other things.
Do you feel like the economic lens is
the predominant lens or are we going to
get to something that you think is
actually even bigger than that? Yeah, I
think the economic lens is the priority,
but there are other issues adjacent to
this economic uh issue. And without
understanding these other issues, we
can't really understand what's really
going on. Because if it was purely an
economic issue, then what America could
do is say to Iran, let's just be
friends. Let's be trading partners,
right? and Iran would be would be ex
ecstatic about uh America lifting
sanctions because the entire point of
negotiating with America on the nuclear
deal was to lift sanctions, right? So um
it was purely economics then America and
Iran would have sat down you know like
1979 1980 whenever and just agreed on an
e economic solution to um their to the
differences and and like 40 years later
there's never been a um serious economic
um solution and so this tells us that
yes economics is at the heart of it
doesn't really fully explain what's
going on. Okay, I want to set the
religious component on the shelf for
now. We'll get to why the right lens is
economics, but however, if you want to
know why people stop being rational
actors, we'll get to that. So, we've got
this McKinder's um heartland thesis. The
British have it. They're fighting
against, you know, first France, then
Russia, like that keeps going for a
while. But the baton handoff from the
Brits to the US running the same
strategy is something that I think
certainly Americans are largely blind
to. Can you walk us through that and why
something that made sense for this tiny
island continues to make sense for you
know the gigantic land mass and economy
that is the US
>> right? So we have to remember like a
much of the reason why Britain was able
to keep its um enemies in the heartland
at bay was because it allied itself with
the Germans, right? So basically
basically it was an alliance with the
Prussians that allowed the British to
defeat the French at the end of the day.
Um but uh in the late 19th century about
1870 uh Germany unified under Bismar
um and now they had their own ambitions
and now Britain came into conflict with
Germany. The Germans were extremely
technologically advanced. They had the
best universities. They were extremely
uh sophisticated cultured people. uh
just the best philosophy in the world
and they had the best general staff in
the world. So um Britain found a
tremendous adversary in Germany. So much
so that it took two world wars to defeat
Germany. So we can argue about the
causes of World War I. But most
historians agree that World War I was
the cause because Britain was a
hedgeimon and Germany was the
challenger, a rising power uh that
threatened the economic imperial
security of Britain and that's what
ultimately led to this uh World War I.
And America came into the war because
quite honestly it seemed as though
Germany was going to triumph in the end.
So it took basically an entire global
alliance to defeat Germany in World War
I. Um the the the tra the tragedy the
travesty of World War I is that in the
Versiles conference the allies made
Germany take all the guilt for causing
World War I which was extremely unfair
and inappropriate and it basically laid
the seeds for World War II. Um, and so
you have World War II and now, uh,
Germany is spreading across Europe and
Germany decides to attack Soviet Union,
which is communist. And you would think
that American Britain would um would
fight alongside the Nazis, but instead
they chose to support u Stalin. And
again, the reason why is the the hard
McKenna thesis. You cannot you cannot
allow a great power to emerge in the
Eurasian climate. And at that time it
seemed that Germany was ascended, right?
Because you if you marry German
technology
um and logistics organization with
Russian manpower and resources, then
this is the empire that rules the world.
So America could not allow that to
happen. But both World War I and World
War II exhausted Britain and it forced
the peaceful transfer of imperial power
from Britain to America. And this was
cemented in something called the bread
and witch conference of 1944 uh which
established the global financial order
that we live in uh today. So so that
that is the story. [snorts]
>> Okay. So the part that I think a lot of
Americans will be a little bit baffled
by is um why is that handoff so obvious
that okay the way to rule the world is
to stick with these shipping lanes. It
makes sense when you've got a small
island. It gets more confusing when the
US is a gigantic land mass with
cooperative neighbors uh to maybe
slightly varying degrees certainly right
now uh to the north and to the south of
them. Um so why did we accept this idea
of trying to patrol the entire world via
the seas? Um, was it just the the call
of being the imperial leader is so
strong and so intoxicating that we're
willing to take on the risk of empire or
was it that well that's what we're going
to have to do to make sure that the
dollar remains the world's reserve
currency.
>> Right? So I think that at the end of
World War II, first of all, there's a
lot of tremendous goodwill um among the
Europeans for for what America did,
right? Right? I mean, because Americans
made a lot of sacrifices to save Europe
from fascism. Um, and so the Europeans
were very grateful. And the real concern
was that if America retreated back into
its continental fortress, which is what
America did at the end of World War I,
then another threat u would arise uh in
Europe, possibly the Soviet Union,
right? Well, I mean, obviously the
Soviet Union. And so the Europeans were
very much interested in ensuring that
America stayed interested in European
affairs and that's what led to the NATO
alliance and the Marshall Plan. Um and
America itself recognized that um if it
did not um help the Europeans then
communism was ascended. Uh communism had
already won in the Soviet Union and it
was clearly going to triumph in China.
And so now you have um a combination of
both uh Soviet Union and China. And so
that really scared American policy uh
makers. So it was in their best interest
to revitalize the Europeans and the
Japanese as soon as possible. And that's
what led of course to the Marshall Plan.
So I think that um it was a combination
of idealism and a combination of
goodwill as well as just real politic uh
long-term strategic planning.
>> Okay. So with that as the backdrop, we
now understand that America's taken the
baton. They're patrolling the seas.
They're um for a very long time, they're
really holding at bay Russia from
becoming the next great power. We end up
winning that largely because Russia just
imploded by not being able to figure out
a successful economic system. Um, now
you get PAX Americana, one government,
the um the monopolar world where they're
just running everything. How does that
end up pushing us towards this moment?
Because for a lot of people that grew up
under that, it was awesome. So you and
I, I think, were actually born in the
same year. So for me, yeah, for me, this
has just been like, yo, this has been
amazing. Uh, and so it's watching it
unravel is deeply distressing, but
seeing it up close, the as an
entrepreneur, the way that I kept
interfacing with something I've heard
you talk about, but using very different
words, is that some people need to be
chased by a lion without hardship,
without having to fight and struggle for
something. The ideas that take root in
people's minds are very distorted. they
begin to think that um the world is just
always going to be peaceful. It that's
just the default stance. And so they're
not thinking about the real things that
it takes to maintain uh hegemonic
structure like we had for so very long.
So when you think about the structural
forces that were at play post the
collapse of the Soviet Union, why did it
get worse and not better?
>> Okay. So to answer this question we have
we have to look at what America's major
imperial innovation was. Okay. So um in
the Britain witch conference 1944 was to
establish the US dollar as the world's
reserve uh currency right uh something
called the exorbitant privilege and uh
America did this to the benefit of
Europe because what this meant was that
America was basically financing the
reconstruction of Europe and Japan right
because Europe uh was devastated by war
and they needed to rebuild the factories
and manufacturing but they needed needed
an outlet [clears throat]
consumers Right. So, Americans agreed to
buy from Europe and and America would
also sell to Europe. Okay. And and the
point was to very quickly build the
manufacturing capacity of Europe as well
as um America. And this is all um made
possible because of the US dollar. The
problem is that when you have fiat
currency, there's always a risk that you
print too much money that you lose
financial discipline. So the agreement
was that uh US dollar would be pegged to
gold. So at any time the Europeans could
reimburse the US dollars for gold. And
so US the US dollar basically became a
contract between uh the Europeans and
the Americans. And this worked out
really well for the first 10 years and
it led to tremendous postwar post-war
prosperity. But over time, the Americans
started to um overreach, started to
abuse this exempt privilege in Vietnam,
right? So basically, America was
financing this silly war in Vietnam that
served no strategic purpose. Um then you
had the space race where America was
spending billions of dollars to send a
man to the moon. And then there was a
great society of Lynen B. Isconin, which
was tremendous for the American people,
but it made the Europeans question how
much gold Americans actually had at Fort
Knox. Um, so the French famously sent um
a frigot, a ship to to New York uh to to
pick up their gold and and take it back
to to France. And after that that let's
that led to something called a Nixon
shock um in 1971 where Richard Nixon
said that the US dollar would no longer
be pegged to uh gold. Uh now you have a
problem like if you're not pegged to
gold then how do you determine the value
of your currency? And so Nixon did two
things which was crucial and bas which
basically established the world order
that we live in today. Okay. The first
thing he did was he signed a deal with
Saudi Arabia where Saudi Arabia would
only sell its oil in US dollars and that
that that led to something called the
petro dollar, right? Which is now the
basis of um the US dollar. And the other
thing that that N did was also that was
also very important which people don't
really discuss is he went to China and
he made a deal with China to become
trading partners where um China would
basically export its cheap labor and in
return [snorts]
they would get US dollars right so this
uh these two deals okay the petro dollar
as well as China become the factory of
the world be the basis of the new global
economy and in in 1999 21 when the
Soviet Union fell, this system then
became um the global financial order and
this was fine. The problem is that um
there was excess capital being produced
around the world and it all went to uh
America. Now at this time America was
shifting its manufacturing to China. So
the economy of America became very
unbalanced and it beca it shifted from a
focus on manufacturing to a focus on
financing on uh so Wall Street started
to you know explode in both financial
and political power and that that led to
hubris and then Wall Street because it
had to create financial vehicles to
absorb all this foreign capital started
to invent all these risky derivatives um
as such as you know the the CDO's um uh
collateral debt obligations and this of
course led to the F 2008 suprime crisis
and at this point in history essentially
the entire global economy should have
collapsed. Why? Because Wall Street had
basically um bundled the entire global
economy together so that if one part of
the system collapsed the entire system
collapsed. and and and I I I know that
you've shared this um uh very well with
your audience, so I won't go too much
into it. The system didn't collapse
because something happened which is that
China bailed out the world by printing
all this money to build infrastructure
throughout China. Okay. So, China
basically became the consumer for the
world. They have all these raw materials
in order to uh build its uh skyscrapers,
its highspeed rail. And that worked out
really well for the world. But then
China said, well, you know what? Before
we were exporting our cheap labor and
now we are financing the global economy,
so we want to have a greater say over
global affairs. We want our companies
like Huawei to go to Africa and sell our
products and compete against Apple. And
the Americans didn't like that. And
that's what led to the Trump tariffs um
in when he came to office in 2016,
right? Um the first thing he did was to
sanction these Chinese companies and
that's led that's led that's what led to
the trade war. Um and so you have all
this instability now in the system
because China is trying to contribute
heavily uh to the global economy but it
wants more political power because of
this and Americans are no we are still
ahead Juman you have to um listen to us.
So the 2008 great financial crisis was a
heavy blow then this trade war of China
was also another heavy blow but the but
the next heavy blow was of course the uh
2022 Russian invasion of Ukraine. Why?
Because after that happened, America
started to use its financial weaponry to
sanction Russia, right? So, it basically
removed Russia from the Swift system and
it um froze Russia's Russian uh $300
billion in assets uh in Europe and in
America. Um and when it did when it did
this, it actually backfired because
remember the entire global financial
order is based on legitimacy and
reputation. And when you steal someone's
money, uh, you destroy your reput
reputation. So Putin's response was,
"Wow, $300 billion is the best money
I've ever spent in order to collapse the
American global financial order." And
um, so this is what's led to a lot of
the issues that we have today where
underpinning uh, uh, the global
financial order is the dollar, but
people don't have as much faith in the
US dollar as possible. So how do you
compensate for that? you compensate for
that by using military power, right?
Right. And this helps us understand this
war in Iran where by going to Iran and
and you know I mean we have to assume
that the Americans under Trump were
planning for a short decisive war to
control uh Iran and once you control
Iran you control the entire strait of
Humus you control all the resources you
can control global trade right also
what's really important is you prevent a
Russia Iran China alliance from forming.
Okay? Because once that happens, watch
China, Russia and Iran come together and
trade and create this trading block. It
achieves the heartland, right? And then
Europe comes in, then Middle East comes
in, then Africa comes in, food breaks.
So from an eomic perspective, Americans
didn't have a choice in the matter in
that the US government was extremely
unstable. It it people didn't have any
faith in it anymore. And so you have to
you had to use force to um remind people
that the US dollar is still the only
global reserve currency. And so they
went into Iran hoping to control that
crucial choke point of resources and
trade. And it's really blow up in their
faces. We'll get back to the show in a
second, but first let's talk about a
clock you can't see. Every day without
active cellular support, you're
compounding damage you won't feel until
it's too late. By the time you notice,
you're already playing catch-up. Most
people's longevity plan is just avoiding
bad stuff. That's not a plan. Real
longevity requires offense. Actively
fortifying your cells every single day.
That's what Nandica by Peak is built to
do. I've tried it and I'm telling you
right now, I am a fan. Nanddica is a
ceremonial cacao neutropic designed to
support your cells from the inside out.
Every ingredient is selected for maximum
bioavailability. The result is calm,
sustained energy, elevated mood, sharper
focus, and [music] you're actively
building long-term cellular resilience
with every cup. Stop playing defense
with your health. Get 20% off at
peaklife.com/impact.
That's piqu.com/impact.
And now, let's get back to the show.
>> This stuff is really good. Okay, so
you've put a couple pieces together that
I think are really important, and I'm
going to say it in a slightly different
way and see if this lands for you. So,
uh, 1971, Nixon breaks the, um, peg to
gold. You become a true fiat currency.
There's now no, um, real tether for you.
the world begins to realize, okay, hold
on a second. This is just fiat. You guys
are going to print out of control like
every empire before you. Uh, and so
Nixon does this brilliant thing and he
finds two avenues to keep making the
dollar um systemically important. He
gets essentially the vast majority of
oil trade to be only transacted in
dollars presumably. You didn't say this,
but I think it's basically we'll protect
you, dear GCC countries. So, you can't
really protect yourself. super exposed
there in the desert. Don't worry, we've
got you. You guys focus on
infrastructure, desalinization, all that
stuff. Uh, and we'll run your military
for you. That works out very well. Hey,
China, we need cheap labor, but hey,
we'll make sure that we're buying a lot
of the stuff that you're producing. Just
make sure that you're also doing trade
in dollars. So you've got energy now
pegged to dollars and you've got this
industrial revolution, not the one that
most people think of when they hear
that, but this new rise of China as the
world's manufacturer also now being tied
to dollars. Then because of course, as
empires do, uh they overextend, they
bully, they do things that ultimately
are against their own interests and we
begin eroding the trust in the dollar,
which is the only thing left on a fiat
currency. And so the part that I want to
reword is when you say that we use our
military to remind people of the power
of the dollar or that we're strong or
whatever. I would say it slightly
differently and this gets to why Iran
becomes so important like what actually
happens in Iran is it isn't enough to
remind everybody that you have a big
military. You actually have to get
control of Iran. You have to control the
oil now. You have to control the
straight of Hormuz. And if you either
are forced to destroy the oil, which now
is going to just have a massive negative
impact on the global economy, or because
of asymmetric warfare, Iran continues to
cause a problem in the straight of
Hormuz and it's technically open, but
every time a US or US allied ship tries
to go through, it gets blown up. Now all
of a sudden, you may have reminded
everybody that you have the stronger
military, but Iran is showing you they
can still control the thing you must get
control of. if you want to win.
>> Okay. Um I would disagree because you
are saying that the Americans went in
hoping for a Venezuela solution, right?
Where they uh removed Maduro and Desert
Rodriguez, the vice president was very
happy to play along. So it's basically a
regime change that favored the
Americans. So let's just discuss how the
interests of Israel and the interest of
Trump are different, right? Because as
as you point out, Trump is interested in
optics. He wants a quick victory. He
wants um uh the Iranians to uh surrender
to him and he wants to be to be able to
control the oil supply so that he when
he goes to Beijing um at the end of this
month um he can negotiate a great deal
for America and he will and he will look
really really uh good, right? Because he
just came off a uh a very decisive
victory in Venezuela. So, you know, he
was very error or again, he's very
confident. That's Trump. But I think
they really are thinking much more long
term and they really want to eliminate
um uh Iran as a threat um in the Middle
East. And this is not the Israelis as
well. If you look at Saudi Arabia, uh
the Saudis have always had issues with
Iranians. So I think it was a coalition
of interest um the Israelis and and the
Saudis who were pushing Trump to attack
Iran. And actually a reporting from uh
the Washington Post actually confirms
this where NBS the head of Saudi Arabia
he was lobbling hard for Trump to attack
the Iranians.
>> The thing that I want to understand
better is given the quagmire that we are
now in with Iran. What are the options
that are on the table especially for
Trump? So if you agree that for the US
to actually have gained ground here,
they need to control the straight of
Hormuz or by some miracle uh get a
friendly government in Iran that will um
maintain control but do things that are
very beneficial to the GCC countries, to
the US, to Israel, um which seem sort of
farther away by the day. But um if he
has to do that, do you think he's going
to push into uh Cara Island and take
over? It's like 94%. Do you think he
goes all the way to a ground invasion?
Um what do you think are the options at
this point given the realities on the
ground?
So what I what I've observed is that
Trump in America um they're behaving
exactly the way that an empire decline
behaves, which is that they suffer from
a toxic and lethal combination of both
hubris and desperation.
um meaning that they continue to
underestimate the resilience and resolve
of the Iranians and they are desperate
for a knockout punch as quickly as
possible. Trump wants this war to end as
soon as possible because he knows that
the longer this war drags on, the worse
the economy will suffer, the worse his
pulling will be and the more likely the
stock market will will tank. So, he's
looking for a knockout punch. And right
now um if you're looking for a quick
solution, if you're looking for a
gamble, well your best option is uh Car
Island because as you point out that is
where uh Iran exports 90% of its oil
primarily to China. So right now a
marine expeditionary force is traveling
from Japan uh to the Middle East and and
we should expect them to arrive maybe in
about a week. And there's there's about
200 of them and they specialize in infib
landing. So the idea is that they will
bombard um the coastline in K Island and
this will enable
um the Marines to land and secure the
oil deposits of K Island. And at this
point Trump will declare victory and try
to get the Iranians to the negotiating
table and says listen I have Kart Island
and this is your economic lifeline. So
let's cut a deal that allows us to uh
both save face. Okay. And I think that
is the plan. But there are a lot of
issues with this plan. Okay. Um the
first issue is that Card Island is not
as important economically as people
believe. Um that's the first issue.
Meaning that even if you were to secure
Kart Island, Iran does have workarounds
where they can just ship from um from
the coast. Um that's issue number one.
Issue number two is that um Iran needs
financing for this war and now they're
using this oil as financing, as
collateral financing. But if the Chinese
and the Russians believe that the
Americans want to strangle Iran, then
it's not in their best interest to see
Iran destroyed, then they're going to
provide financing anyway. And look, the
reality is that now that oil is shooting
up in price, this benefits Russia
tremendously, right? So Putin can take
all this oil riches and finance Iran um
in fighting this war because Russia has
the most to lose if Iran loses this war
and there's regime change. So that's
issue number two.
>> You think Russia has more to lose than
China?
>> I I I do I do. Um and the reason why is
that if [snorts] Iran were to fall, this
opens up the Russian southern flank to
the Americans, right? because uh Azar
Bajan is an Israeli American ally and um
if Iran were to fall then um the
Americans and Israelis could could stage
operations uh from the south also um
also Iran has been providing a lot of
support to uh Russia in the Ukraine war.
So Russia is getting most of its drones
from Iran. So um uh foreign minister uh
Sergey Lavough has said that uh Russia
will protect Iran and Russia is most
interested in um the Iran government
staying intact. And there's been
reporting from American news outlets
that American intelligence believes that
Russia's providing targeting for the
Iranians. So, uh, all these drone
strikes, all these ballistic missile
strikes, it's they're getting
intelligence and targeting from the
Russians, which by the way is what NATO
did in Ukraine, right? So, from the
Russian perspective, it's payback. So,
the Russians are heavily invested in um
in the Iranians winning this war. The
Chinese are pramatic. They don't they
really don't care. They see Iran more as
a major supplier of oil that they that
they need. But if they need to shift um
uh supply routes, they they can they can
do so, right? So the Russians are
heavily um uh invested um and so they
would finance uh the Iranians regardless
if Iran is no long no longer able to
export oil. Okay. Uh and another issue
is this. If you attack the economic
lifeline of Iran, they now have
incentive to strike at the oil
refineries of the GCC, right? because no
matter how much economic damage you can
do to Iran, they can do so much more to
the GCC. Um, and this would cause the
oil, the price of oil to spike.
Remember, Iranians have said that their
goal is to uh spike the price of oil to
$200 a barrel. Now, it's about $100 a
barrel. And so, what they're saying is
that we're going to fight a very long
war of attrition that could last years.
Um so so I I don't see what the
strategic benefit of taking Cart island
is. And the last problem and this is the
most important is that um once you take
Clark Island you expose the Marines to
drone strikes and artillery strikes from
the coast which means that you now need
to send in more Marines to secure the
coast. Right? So you sent in 2,000 3,000
troops to secure Car Island. done that
easily. Um um but they can't secure they
can't secure the island against uh
Iranian drones. So the only way you can
do that is by taking taking the
coastline along Clark Island. You do
that with tens of thousands of uh
marines. But then you you expose um this
these marines to attacks from the
mountains, the Zagros mountains, right?
these drones, these missiles from the
Zagos mountains, which means that now
you have to invest 100,000 troops to go
after Iran's um underground missile
facilities. And this is exactly what
happened in uh Vietnam. The great irony
of all this is that the um marine
expeditionary force that is going to um
Iran is the same force that went into
Vietnam and marked the um the first
major ground involvement of the
Americans in about 1965. Uh they
basically went into Dagnan and secured
the Air Force base. And at first it was
like 3,500 soldiers and that that was
supposed to be it. like five years later
you're at 500,000 American soldiers
right so once you send in ground troops
then it creates a logic a momentum of
its own and then you have mission creep
and then some cost fallacy um and then
eventually you have a natural draft okay
so that is a great danger of taking Car
Island at this point
>> okay so let's um keep pushing down that
road because I think that uh you're bang
on with this I think if Trump puts boots
on the around in Iran. I think he can
get away with Car Island because it will
be small. It will feel like, hey, we're
doing this very discreet thing. We can
take it in, you know, a couple days.
We've got it now. He'll declare that
that's a big win for us. We control 94%.
He buys himself a little bit of time.
Most people don't know what you just
said, which is Iran has other options.
So, that's going to feel, going back to
Trump equals optics. Uh, it's going to
feel like an optical win. The thing that
scares me is I think to your point he
will end up getting drawn into boots on
the ground because one he'll have seen
oh the American people didn't super
freak out. Okay that's great. We all
start going well I mean I guess we
already have boots on the ground so it's
not so crazy that we go like just try to
finish the job real quick. Uh you know I
but by doing that I think that his base
implodes. I think he is a guaranteed
loss at the midterms and I think given
the political dynamic in the US where we
are so hyperpolarized
that it becomes existential for him in
terms of he will go to prison. So if he
loses the midterms he gets impeached
immediately. He then obviously loses
power in uh 2028 which needs to happen
no matter what given that right now our
constitution makes very clear uh no
third term for you. But I think that we
would I mean look many many a thing can
happen between now and the 2028
elections. But I would imagine if Trump
goes down, the Republican party loses
power, Democrats get into office, they
have already vowed that they're going to
go after him legally. So I have a
feeling he's going to fight like this is
existential. So he's going to start
making decisions that would seem
rational to anybody else or irrational
to anybody else will seem rational to
him because he absolutely must find a
way to victory better to prolong it,
leverage a war to stay in power, etc.,
etc. Um, so walk me through if you think
any of that analysis is off base or if
I'm missing something. Um, but what do
you see if he makes the fateful decision
to go after Car Island?
>> Yeah. No, I I agree with your analysis.
I think a lot of his thinking is how
does he stay in power? Because we know
exactly what's going to happen if he
leaves office. The Democrats are going
to come to power and they're going to go
after uh him and his family. We know
this because that's what happened in uh
2020 when when remember the raid in Mara
Lago, remember all these uh all this
lawfare against Trump. Remember that he
lost his court case and almost
bankrupted him. Okay. So, you can
imagine that there's going to be a lot
of people who want revenge for what
Trump is doing in his s second term. So,
Trump cannot afford to leave office. And
so, his personal calculus is how do I
stay in power? Well, staying in power
for the back ballot ballot box is, you
know, very risky. But you know if he
starts a war and this war is at first
supported by both the Democrats and the
Republicans but then um slowly this war
spirals out of control and then um
there's a lot of unrest around America
in which case he's forced to send a
national guard um and then he's forced
to call the National Draft in order to
protect American interests in um the
Middle East then he can conceivably stay
in power uh for as long as this war
continues. news and and we know this
because of what happened with Zilinski
uh in Ukraine and remember because of
the war.
>> Yeah, exactly. Because of the war in
Ukraine, they suspended their
constitution and they suspended
elections and Zilinski is is still still
in power. And remember when Zilinski
visited Trump in the White House, um
Trump asked Zilinski, hey, hey, you can
you really do that? Uh and then Zilinski
is like, you like this, don't you?
Right. So, um I think unfortunately that
is going through the mind of Trump right
now. Um I just want to step back and um
because a lot of people are saying,
"Wasn't Trump just declare victory and
go home?" The problem with this is if
Trump were to leave the Middle East,
basically the American empire would
collapse. So, let's go over using game
theory what happened if Trump were just
to say, "You know what? You know, I
killed the leadership. I destroyed the
nuclear weapons program. I set back the
ballistics program. Everything I wanted
to accomplish, I've already
accomplished. I'm going to go home,
guys. Goodbye. Okay. What happened is
this. Iran would say to the GCC, "Hey,
you've destroyed our country. You have
to pay back reparations. If you don't
pay back reparations, first of all,
we'll continue to attack you and destroy
your oil infrastructure. And second of
all, we won't let we won't let you use
the trade of home moves. And so now the
GCC is forced to take a $4 trillion
dollars in sovereign wealth funds.
Before this money was going to United
States, now it's going to Iran to build
back their economy and infrastructure
and their military, right? But then the
Japanese and the South Koreans are like,
hm, well, we just saw what hap what
happened, right? where the Americans
attacked Iran and Iran fought back and
destroyed the GCC and the Americans
refused to defend the GCC. Remember the
entire point of this petro dollar
agreement is that Americans would
guarantee the security of the GCC. Uh
and when this war started out, what we
know happened is that the Americans
abandoned their bases, changed into
civilian clothes and moved into hotel
into hotels because they could not stop
the Iranians from raining drones and
ballistic missiles on their bases. So
the South Koreans and the Japanese will
be like, "Okay, well, we can't trust
Americans, so we need to remmilitarize
as soon as possible. So let's just um
not depend on the Americans and
remilitarize." But that what all what
that also means is they stop buying US
treasuries, right? And so the US dollar
uh loses
um buyers from the Middle East and loses
buyers from East Asia. And so the dollar
could potentially collapse in value and
now America has $40 trillion in debt. Uh
which which forces an economic crisis in
America, a great reset, uh financial
depression. But you you'll have riots um
in the streets and then you go to
Europe, the Europeans are like the
Americans are um suffering from
depression and the Americans are not
able to defend their allies. Why are we
fighting the Russians again? Why don't
we just come to an agreement with the
Russians? Why are we sending our man to
die in Ukraine? Right? So now Russia
becomes the dominant power in Europe and
Iran becomes the dominant power in the
Middle East and America is you know uh
imploding u back in western hemisphere.
Is is that a situation that the American
government that Trump would would um
count? I don't think it is. Uh so so
there's really no possibility of America
retreating from this war. America can
only escalate unfortunately.
>> Yeah. There's another piece that I think
um is getting lost in all of this which
is Trump went to the Middle East and
secured I don't know call it two
trillion dollars in uh investment
promises into the US which will largely
go into AI infrastructure and if he
doesn't manage to restabilize the Middle
East and make sure that the GCC
countries don't have to spend that money
on their own defense. uh they're going
to pull all of that money to defend
their country. That causes a shock, a
potential collapse of the AI bubble or
burst of the AI bubble. And so right
now, the American stock market, so as
you well know, we have a grotesqually
K-shaped economy. And the only thing
propping up spending right now is that
the wealthy few at the top are still
buying a bunch of stuff. And that
creates this illusion that the economy
is doing okayish.
And that stops if AI implodes. And AI
doesn't have to not be real. AI is real.
But if the money stops flowing in,
they're not able to get the
infrastructure investments they need to
see this across the finish line so that
the revenues can catch up because right
now there's still a massive gap. Um we
find ourselves in a position where the
one thing propping up the US economy,
poof, goes away. Um, and so it's like
everything you just said and then
squared because you've got the second uh
thing waiting in the wings. If the first
one doesn't kill the dollar, the second
one could kill the um thing holding up
the economy.
>> Well, I completely agree. Um, it's a
very dire situation.
>> Okay. So, as we look at this, um, when I
was trying to map, uh, come up with a
mental model for why Trump was pushing
the issue to go to war with Iran, I was
legitimately confused in the beginning
because I understood the attack on Ford.
It's like, okay, they're about to get
nuclear weapons. They chant death to
America. Let's just blow up their
nuclear sites. Cool. Did it. Hey,
everybody, we demolished it. And then
like all of a sudden, he starts talking
about, well, we're sending all these
boats to Iran. And I was like, why? I
don't understand what's happening. And
so then you've got all the uprisings and
just more and more and more and more
ships. Like we're going to help them
out. All is well. But then we didn't
move at the peak of them killing 30,000
plus civilians. So then I was like, what
are we doing? And so then he starts
talking about nuclear weapons again. And
I'm just like, hold on a second. I
thought that we already destroyed the
nuclear capabilities. So what are we
doing for me to make this all make
sense? I was like, hold on a second. If
you inject Thusidities trap and you
understand we've got a rising China, a
declining America, then I'm like, this
all makes sense. If Venezuela and Iran
are a one-two punch to try to do
whatever amount of quarantining or
economic damage that we can do to China
to make sure that they don't have access
to cheap oil that's outside of our
ability to sanction. I'm like, this at
least makes sense. I'm not saying you
should do it. I'm just saying I can
follow your chain of logic. Um, one
thing you'll talk about China for sure,
but you don't often mention Thusidity's
trap. Do you think Thusidity's trap is
overblown? Um, do you think it just
doesn't apply here? What's your thinking
on could that have been the reason that
Trump actually made the move?
>> So, this is a great question and so let
us just assume that Trump is rational
and that there's a logical strategy
behind all this maneuvering uh in the
Middle East. And the best explanation is
that right now Trump is trying to
negotiate with China, right? Trump right
now understands that the United the US
dollar is a Ponzi scheme. So it needs
more consumers to buy into this Ponzi
scheme. And China for all its problems
uh the household savings rate in China
is 40%. So there's this untapped market
in China that Trump wants to uh access.
But how do you force China to agree to
let Chinese consumers buy US dollars?
Well, you do it by strangling the
Chinese economy because remember the
Chinese economy is export driven.
Therefore, it's reliant on on imports
like oil and food. Uh China imports
about a third of its food and 23 of its
oil. China gets a lot of of its food
from the Western Hemisphere um uh
primary South America, right? So that's
why we saw uh Trump announcing the
mineral doctrine the Trump corally to
the mineral doctrine where the Americans
would control the entire western
hemisphere. So if China wanted to trade
with the western hemisphere the
Americans have have to collect a tax or
or a toll and we're seeing this play out
in Venezuela where um the Chinese are
continuing to buy Venezuelan oil but
they they pay they pay the Americans a
tax or or whatever. Okay, so that's the
strategy in Western Hemisphere and Iran
makes sense because uh China imports
most of its oil actually from the GCC,
right? So once you control Iran and you
control the Hummus, then you basically
strangle uh uh China and now China is
forced to buy more oil from the
Americans, the Canadians and the
Mexicans. Um and and so that would
resolve the great financial crisis
America is facing. It would basically
save the US dollar. So from a rational
perspective this does hold okay like but
there are certain issues with this
thesis okay the first issue is that from
the e economic perspective it's very
risky to use military force to resolve
an economic issue you don't actually
have to go and occupy Venezuela or
attack Iran you can negotiate a grand
bargain where or a new trade alliance
which is more like bricks you know a
more uh collaborative model. Okay,
that's issue number one. Uh issue number
two is I think this fusilities trap is
overblown. Okay, so let let me explain
my reasoning. I think that China and the
United States are codependent.
What I mean by that is that in 1980s
America did offshore its manufacturing
to China. What China did which and which
people don't really discuss is China
offshore its elite selection and
indoctrination to America meaning that
the Chinese elite uh were educated in
American colleges and universities and
so they have a very American mindset in
many ways uh China has been coloni sorry
sorry America has colonized China okay
America and and so um the Chinese elite
are very pro-american.
Um, and so you don't really have to uh
strangle China. You just you just have
to be like make a deal with China. You
just have to be nice China because the
Chinese are desperate [snorts] for a
deal. And there are many ways that this
deal could benefit itself, right? So
Trump has talked about welcoming 600,000
Chinese students to America. Uh Trump
has talked about um selling um digital
currency to the uh to to Chinese
consumers, right? Basically just um um
uh tokens backed by US treasuries. So
there are a lot of mechanisms that he
has to resolve this this issue. I really
think this US China uh conflict is
overblown.
um primarily because China is not
interested in being a hegeimon. It's not
even interested in um controlling a
sphere of influence in Southeast Asia.
China is first and foremost interested
in maintaining its national sovereignty
um and um and and creating trade routes
that benefit the Chinese people. Um, and
I think the American pol policy makers
understand this and I think that these
this China threat has always has always
been overblown to justify a lot of um
bloated spending in Washington DC,
right? So an example is AI where um um
you know the Americans are like you know
we need to spend all this money on AI
because if we don't do this then the
Chinese will will do this. Okay. Okay.
So, China is this um imagined threat for
for many uh decades. And the last thing
I will say is that people do not
appreciate the level of cooperation
between the Chinese and the Americans um
in this world. So the classic example is
if you look at what's happen
Chinese ships are able to pass through
okay and Americans are not doing
anything to stop them. In fact, the
Americans, Scott Bessant, the the church
secretary, has said that we're allowing
this happen to maintain stability in the
global financial order. And both the
Chinese and Americans are are
cooperating to maintain the stability of
the global financial order, the global
economy, but the Russians and Iranians
are interested in prop destroying uh the
global economy and creating a new
economic system that benefits them.
Okay. So, so people don't appreciate
that uh in terms of just pure economic
interest, America and China are lied and
against Iran and Russia, if that makes
sense.
>> It it certainly makes sense. It is very
different than certainly the mental map
that I have of what's going on and
probably the mental map of a lot of
Americans. Uh which is the absolute
fascinating part about getting to talk
to somebody like you who is for people
that don't know your backstory, I'll
speedrun it. Correct me if anything is
incorrect. Uh, born in China. You
immigrate to um, Canada when you're six.
You are Ivy League trained here in the
US, but end up going, I think, right
back after college, heading back to
China, uh, where you now live. We're
speaking to you uh, from Beijing, if I'm
understanding it all correctly. Uh,
you're a teacher there at a private
school, but everything that you post
online is in English, so I presume that
your classes are taught in English. Um,
so you have a really fascinating lens.
um Chinese by birth and nationality,
trained in the west, uh educated, grew
up in the west, feeling quite alienated,
go back to China, uh but still is like
sort of a um somebody with a more
western mindset. Again, don't want to
put words in your mouth, but it it is a
very interesting lens with which to look
at this problem. So, first, did I
represent the history accurately enough?
>> No. No, it it was very fair and kind.
Yes. Okay, perfect. So now um my mental
map is that what's happening in the
world right now is really a question of
US and China. Um I'm looking at it very
much like you. So it's interesting that
we draw different conclusions. So I
think uh for people that don't know you,
which these days is a vanishingly small
number of people, but um you've got two
issues. One, that you're looking at the
world through the lens of game theory,
and two, you're leveraging history to
tell us what we're going to see in the
future. And so when you look backwards
at history, 12 of the last 16 times that
a rising superpower collided with a
declining superpower, exactly like the
US and China, they went to war. So it's
like whatever 75% of the time, this ends
in war. And so I've been looking at much
of Trump's movements, who's somebody
who's been banging the drum about China
for a very long time, much longer than
he's been a political figure, and
saying, "Okay, this is a guy that's had
his eye on China for a long time, who
either intuitively or actually
intellectually understands uh America's
decline, understands China's rise, and
is trying to find some sort of
equilibrium. He's the art of the deal
guy. So I think you're right. He's
perfectly willing to cooperate to get a
deal done to not um I don't think that
Trump is going to make any play
whatsoever to um infringe on China in
its sphere of influence. But you're the
first person I've heard say that China
doesn't want uh a sphere of influence.
All they want is to be uh sovereign. So
that is like the first bit of dissonance
where um I'm intrigued. I will certainly
sit with it. My whole worldview is about
you're wrong about something, so you
might as well race to figuring out what
it is. And so, hey, maybe my whole frame
of reference around thusidity strap just
isn't accurate. But I'm going to have a
hard time metabolizing that one. I'm not
going to lie. Um, so
for instance,
help an American audience understand
right now some percentage of us, I
certainly don't think we're um,
homogenized thinkers, but some
percentage of us see us at war with
Iran. China now has all these ships and
planes circling Taiwan. We all look at
that as like escalation. the people who
think like this, which I am definitely
one of, and go, "Oh, China
[clears throat] is now seeing us with
our eye off the ball." They've said
forever that by 2027 they want to
reunite with Taiwan, um, which would be
a huge blow to our perceived modern way
of life because of TSMC. And so that
feels like given that and the gold
corridor in South America and some of
the moves with the belt and road
initiative um just feel like China's
being more strategically aggressive than
it sounds like you think they are.
So help us understand why that's wrong.
>> All right. Okay. So the fusidities trap
was coined by a Harvard historian named
Graham Graham Allison and he did it
through his reading of fusidities the
pelibian war. Okay. So I wanted to
correct um uh the understanding of the
of the Pelibanian war, right? Because
the war started in uh Fidilities
formulation because Sparta was a
hegeimon and Athens was the rising power
and fides was wrong. Okay? And so so let
me explain why Sparta and Athens
actually wanted nothing to do with each
other. Uh Sparta was an agricultural
power and Athens was a naval power. Um,
so the the Spartans had a plantation
economy where their [snorts] entire
system was based on exploiting slave
labor, but because they did that, they
were outnumbered by the slaves 10 to1.
And so they were always afraid of a
slave revolt. And that was a consistent
problem throughout the history because
the sparrants were notoriously brutal.
And as such, they develop a very
conservative insular society.
Um, and they were not interested in
international affairs. Um the Athenians
were very different. The Athenians were
a trading power and so they were very
expansionist. They were very ambitious.
Um we know about the two because of the
Persian wars. So the Persians invaded
the Greek mainland and the Spartans and
the Athenians were forced to come
together to repel this uh invasion. But
after this invasion was repelled, the
Spartans were like, "We're going to go
home and we're going to stay in our land
and don't bother bother us ever again."
And then the Athenians created something
called the Dalian League, okay, which
was alliance um very much like NATO
today. But over time, the Athenians
started to abuse their allies and turn
them into vassels. And then these vassal
states start to rebel against the
Athenians. And this is what led
ultimately to the Palestinian war. And
then spotter was dragged into
unwillingly into this war and then
Persia was as well. So it's not as easy
as Graeme Ellison and Fusidities are
making out to be. And there are par
parallels to our Mar society where it
seems as though China and America are at
war. They're in conflict because these
are two economic hegeimons. Do you think
about it? The real issue is that America
is trying to exploit its allies. Right?
So, let's go back to two two months ago
when Trump was saying, "I'm going to
take over Greenland. I'm going to take
over Canada. I'm going to take over the
entire Western Hemisphere." And you
Europeans, you need to pay more in NATO
spending. You need to move up to 5%. And
also, I'm going to charge you tariffs
for trade because we're America. We're
indispensable and you have to follow
along because you're vassels, right? So
that's really the real conflict going on
in this world where America is trying to
maintain the unipolar order and its
allies see that America has become
arrogant um and is engaged in bullying
behavior. So they're trying to break
away somehow and ultimately uh if we
just read the Palestinian war, this will
lead to open conflict between America's
allies and America eventually and then
perhaps China Russia will be dragged in.
But ultimately
um China and Russia don't want a
conflict with uh America. So so so does
that make sense to you? I I mean, it's
certainly believable that nobody
wants a war with another great power.
It's just so destructive and can take so
many years. I can certainly buy why
Russia um is creating um
because of what's going on in Ukraine,
they would really not want to be a part
of this. Uh now, I've read enough about
Xi and how he's sort of the uh what's
the phrase? the ambition grows in the
Eden, right? They've had China's had I
don't have to tell you, but so much
incredible success over the last 40
years. I mean, it's really breathtaking.
And that has to leave somebody with a
feeling of like we could we can do even
more. Now, this is so interesting and
I'm so grateful to you for letting me um
say these theories out loud to somebody
who's really in the middle of it. Uh so
in my reading about China and Xi
specifically, there's this idea of the
middle kingdom. And so a big part of my
mental map of why I think this is like
the most perfect Thusidity trap ever is
that China's gone through, you know, the
century of humiliation. You guys come
out of that, never again. We're not
doing that anymore. We're thinking very
long range. We're going to take our
power back. And you've actually done it.
And so just like Trump strikes Venezuela
and realizes, oh, like I've got a really
good military. Uh, I can like really
start doing some stuff here. I look at
China and I go, "How do you guys not
look at what you've accomplished and go,
"Oh, okay." Like, we need to be
methodical. We need to be thoughtful and
maybe we've got a housing crisis right
now, so maybe we need to chill for a
minute, but we know how to play this
game, and so we're going to keep going,
keep going, keep going. And so, from the
Western lens, it looks like Xi's
consolidating power. He's purging the
military because he wants to get
everybody aligned with his future vision
where he wants to take things and it
feels like somebody who thinks hey this
is all working. I've got ambitions, but
they're in terms of look at the gold
corridor, right? So, just, you know,
China wants to get out from under the
dollar. They're selling their debt.
They're again, this is speculation based
on watching how you're moving, but the
um banks in China, the central banks are
buying up a ton of gold. They're talking
about, hey guys, we're going to back our
currency. uh they're a little
wishy-washy about that, but they're
buying so much gold and then appealing
to the world to use the yuan as the
reserve currency. You start putting two
and two together and you go, "Oh, I get
the play." Talking about housing gold
actually in other countries and if they
can find a partner that will back them
and say, "Hey, we vouch. The gold is
here. It's not controlled by China.
We've got it." like you can just the
moves are so smart that I cannot help
but then project onto it that this is
somebody who's not stopping now. And so
um that's where I bump into the looking
at China as just completely sanguin and
like yeah I don't want any conflict. I
get that they don't want open conflict.
I can totally buy that. But they've got
the big agenda with Taiwan and they've
made so many smart um ally moves that if
I'm China and I'm watching the US
alienate all of their allies while I've
been building all of mine while they're
shooting themselves in the face
economically and okay, we've got a
little bit of woes here, but like we're
going to get back on track. We're far
more disciplined, 40, you know, percent
savings, all that. um that just creates
this mental model that I have of the
ascendant China who's not going to be
told what to do by a clearly
dysfunctional United States.
>> I think that's a great analysis and uh I
think absolutely right in that China has
been singling its intention to replace
the American uh financial order with a
new break system um based on gold. Um
and that's why it's creating the
Shanghai gold corridor. So I think that
I I think what you say makes a lot of
sense and I think it's it's really um
part of Chinese policy making to create
as much um economic diversity in the
world as possible to hedge against the
Americans.
The way I look at the world is through
game theory. Um and for me what's really
important is how nations have behaved in
the past. So when you say the middle
kingdom uh the middle kingdom from a
Chinese perspective just means that we
don't care about the rest of rest of the
world. uh we've never really cared about
the rest of the world. All we care about
is the internal sta stability of China
because historically and this is very
important is that China has been poor
and corrupt and so rebellions against
the government are very common place and
so your entire uh state apparatus is
structured to ensure that local
rebellions don't arise and in the 1980s
there was a solution to this problem of
local rebellions.
uh when basically the communist system
had an agreement where we will engage in
economic reform and we will allow the
elite to engage in corruption. Okay. Um
and so that incentivize the elite to
um uh promote economic reform and turn
away from the old socialist model of of
maone. Um and and in 1980s this was very
controversial. uh but because of the
financial incentives they elite engage
in market reform but then you have a
tremendous corruption problem also where
was this money going right they were
engaging this corruption they weren't
putting in China because um it was not
safe because they were stealing this
from the government right so this was
being transferred overseas to America to
um Canada and look I mean like I don't
want to specifics but I would tell you
like the amount of capital uh that was
being transferred overseas was just
tremendous. Okay. Uh so much so that
really uh the Chinese economy is now
suffering under a deflationary uh
spiral. Okay. But it was it was not just
capital that went overseas. It was also
the elite that went overseas. Right? The
children, the families of the elite all
are now overseas. And I don't want to go
go into specifics, but you know, if they
are overseas, where where are their
national interests aligned, right? They
want peace and harmony between China and
America because they see China as a
plantation economy where they can
continue to exploit the economy and then
take their ilgen and then and then take
it over to the western joy, a western
lifestyle. Okay? And for many decades,
this was just the way business was done
in China. and it worked to the
tremendous benefit of the Chinese elite
as well as the western economies. And
then when President Xi came to power, he
recognized that this is not sustainable
in the long term. Eventually, our
economy is going to collapse.
Eventually, we're going to have
rebalance all over the place. And so, he
started to clamp down on corruption and
he started to focus on national
rejuvenation, on creating a national
identity. And from him, for his from his
perspective, the way you do that is
through uh unifying with Taiwan and
establishing an an independent economic
system um that is based on the Chinese
yen as opposed to US dollar. So um that
was his intention. But again, the
reality is that China is a very corrupt
place. Uh and so the elite are rebelling
against him. And so these past two years
um you know and this public information
most of the generals in the military
have been purged uh for corruption
issues for other issues as well meaning
like the military does not have the
political will to engage in a foreign
conflict anywhere um so so yes I
understand there's the intention of the
state but then there's the cultural
reality in which we live in
if this makes any sense.
Sorry. [clears throat]
>> Makes a tremendous amount of sense. Uh
it is the kind of thing that explains
your absolute meteoric rise. This is uh
a very very useful conversation. I'm I'm
very grateful. Okay. So, um that's a
very clear picture of China that is very
different I think than the common person
in America would view it as. I'm going
to put that back on the shelf. uh let it
sort of sit in the background as we get
back to Iran and look at what I want to
talk about is we've got those two
things. So we've got China's the
realities of everything. We've got US
empire acting the way that failing
empires do. They're flailing. They're
acting like bullies. They're
overextending. They're getting
themselves in trouble doing anything
that they can to hold on to uh the
vestages of their empire. um a thesis
that you've put forward that I find very
compelling is that the current world
order, the postworld war II order, the
um monolithic US as global hegeimon,
those those world orders are done.
They're already dead. And maybe you're
watching the death rows or whatever, but
the new world order is coming. And I
want to understand what does the new
world order look like? And as with Iran
as pivot point, what does it look like?
How does this play out? How deep do we
go? Um and
why is there no sort of ability to
preserve the current world order? First
of all, the entire the current global
economic order is based on the premise
of cheap oil, right? Because cheap oil
is basis for everything. You know, like
from the home moves, you're not you you
don't just have energy, you also have
fertilizer which allows you to grow
food. You also have suffered acid which
is which is what allows you to process
um semiconductors. Okay. So cheap oil,
cheap energy is the basis for the entire
global economy. The reality is the shoo
is not going to open tomorrow. It's
probably going to stay closed for the
next few years.
>> Meaning like the world loses access to
cheap oil. Okay. So we we need to think
ahead and see what this means for the
rest of the world. And so I would say
there are three major trends that we
should expect in next four to five
years. All right. And I think I think
these trends will be very very uh
salient. Um, so the first major trend is
de-industrialization and deurbanization.
Meaning that it doesn't really make
sense to have millions of people live in
cities doing digital work. Uh, why?
Because the economy is not balanced. You
need people to grow food and then you
need manufacturing as well. Before you
didn't have to worry about this because
it was a globalized economy where you
can import food. All right? And like
just just just think about how if you're
a middle- class American, you basically
have a higher state of living than the
Roman emperor because you could, you
know, every day go to supermarket and
eat avocados, cherries, um you could
have food from all around the world all
the time. And again, this is because of
access to cheap oil. Um um but that
those days are gone. And you and
basically like economies need to become
a much more balanced economy and that
means moving people from the cities
especially young people and moving them
back to the rural areas so that they can
grow food and be self-sufficient. Okay,
that's that's going to be trend number
one. Number two is like before
globalization was the religion was the
faith of the times but now but now that
globalization is collapsing because
American power can no longer support
globalization nations need to reassert
themselves. Okay. So, you have the rise
of uh nationalism which then allows for
remilitarization in order to protect
their borders be better, right? Because
before you can just rely on American
military power for protection, but now
you have to defend yourself, right? And
you do that through um rejuvenating
people's sense of national pride and
identity. Okay? So, nationalism
remilitarization is the second big
trend. The third big trend is uh
mercantileism. Okay. basically
self-sufficient economic spears spheres
around the world and it's going to look
it's going to look different differently
in different places where Europe might
be a trading block onto itself but in
other places maybe Israel maybe Japan um
create their own economic zones for
military power right um so and then in
the northern hemisphere um I think that
America will come out okay because
really I mean like like America is a
superpower regardless right so America
retreats from the rest of the world But
it but then it um builds an e economic
system within the western hemisphere and
then it's fine. So so so so we're seeing
a rupture or splintering of the world
and going back basically to 1930s.
That's wild. Okay. So who are going to
be the winners and who are going to be
the losers in this?
>> Right. So basically um whoever whichever
nation is most able to embrace these
trends and transform the economies from
one that is globally um dependent to
much more nationally dependent will
survive. Okay. So um that's why I think
like Japan in Asia is actually better
position than China because the Chinese
economy is to export
orientated. Okay, China, the Chinese
economy just just relies on dumping
cheap goods onto the global market and
you can do that again with cheap oil and
a global marketplace. But once you know
nations start to go into war and then
they they no longer trade then China is
forced to um become much more insular
and unfortunately the Chinese economy is
not balanced meaning like it's
completely depend on exports and
consumers don't actually have any demand
because because consumers don't have any
capital they don't have any savings to
spend money on uh consumers are afraid
of the future they lack confidence okay
so China is in a very tough situation
because the Chinese economy economy and
Chinese planners are not able to make
the transition from one that is a global
economy to one that is a much more um uh
regional economy. Okay. Japan on the on
the other hand has a history and a
record of making radical transformations
when the existence of the nation is at
stake. Okay. So you just you just look
at Japan you think oh my god Japan is
completely screwed because they have an
aging crisis because they are uh
completely dependent on resources from
abroad. they don't actually have their
own oil. Um, and the Japanese economy
has been in a deflationary spiral for
the past 20 30 years. Okay? You think
Japan is completely screwed. But when
you when all hope seems lost, the
Japanese somehow come together
and then transform their entire their
entire system. Okay? And so this goes so
I'll give you some a few examples where
you know um in the 1200s or 1300s when
the Mongolians were coming to invade
Japan and Japan at this time was you
know like feudal uh system they couldn't
gather as a people and we and we post
the Mongol invasion not once but twice.
Okay that's very impressive. Then you go
go to major re reformation right which
is the mid 19th century when China had
already been carved up by the western
powers and Japan's like okay we need to
industrialize now and they did so in 20
years
>> all right so much so that yeah so much
so that Japan defeated Russia in the
RussoJapanese war
um and and then you go you go to the end
of World War II when the Japanese
economy was completely devastated so
what happened the Japanese people came
together and in 20 years time they
became the world's dominant
manufacturing power. Okay, the Japanese
are a special people never ever bet
against the Japanese. So even though the
things look darkest for the Japanese,
they they they are remarkably resilient
people uh and cohesive people. So I
think like they are the most likely to
make the transformations necessary in
order to survive the new um global
order. Another thing I will say is the
aging crisis where every industrial
economy is suffering from the aging
crisis, right? You have people living
into the 90s uh into the hundreds and
they're not working but they are just
consuming a lot of resources and every n
industrial nation is going to suffer
from this issue. Um, but the Japanese
are different. Meaning like if you if
the Japanese nation is is under stress
and there's a crisis and the elderly in
Japan need to make the necessary
sacrifices in order for their
grandchildren
to survive. They will do so. And no
other nation in the world will do this.
Okay? Get the baby boomers in America to
make sacrifices for America. I mean, you
you can you can you can make argument
like a lot of the issues in America come
from the fact that the baby boomers are
a selfish, materialistic
uh and self-absorbed generation that
refuse to surrender power, right? I
mean, like like look at the baby look
how old the Congress is. You got this
guy Chuck Grassley. How how old is like
94 or something? He's still in he's
still there. What is he doing?
Yeah, it it is. I have to admit it is
pretty wild. Uh yeah, Japan is a unique
case. It brings up the question. So,
you're talking about uh people are going
to get more nationalistic because
they're going to have to defend their
own interests and Japan is a special use
case. Expect them to become a regional
power because of their ability to
coales, come together. Japan is also
making waves here in the US because
they're being so xenophobic and uh
absolutely just deciding, yeah, yeah,
yeah, we're we're not doing any more uh
immigration, which is crazy given that
they have this aging population, they
have this demographic challenge, and
they're going to, you know, get rid of
one of the easiest, maybe not the best,
but one of the easiest ways to deal with
it. Um, I've heard you say some things
that to Western ears is quite striking
about diversity not being a useful thing
at this time. Um, talk to me a little
bit about that. What's what's the thesis
there?
>> Right. So, um, the idea is that um,
after World War II there was a lot of
discussion as to why World War II
happened and the agreement was excessive
nationalism, right? these nations like
Japan and Germany became fascists. And
so what we need to do is dilute the
national fever of people around the
world and then you have eternal peace.
And so a concept that came into
popularity at this time is something
called the open society where you have
open borders, multiculturalism,
diversity and I celebrate it as a way to
create um common bonds among humanity.
And for for the longest time this made a
lot of sense and clearly I benefited
from this from this because I was I was
allowed to immigrate from a poor village
in China to go to Toronto um and then
get a full scholarship to study at Yale.
So I clearly benefit from this system.
But now we've reached an extreme where
um to have any um sense of community to
want to belong to a group is considered
racist and um backward and provincial.
And I think that's just wrong. I mean
like uh I mean like I've been watching
um the spread of DEI um in the United
States and I just think it's it's just
like it doesn't make any sense to me.
Um, I I I appreciate diversity. I appre
I appreciate multiculturalism,
but to make it your official religion
and to punish anyone who wants more
balance in society, who wants to protect
the American identity, I think I think
it's it I mean like it's just uh wrong.
Um I think it's just fanatical. Um and
and I think like if you embrace too much
multiculturalism, which is what the
Europeans are doing, it will lead to
eventually suicide, national suicide.
Okay, so the example is in 2014,
you have you have millions of these um
refugees from the Middle East fleeing
war and terror created by the Americans
and they're going to Europe. And quite
honestly, the Europeans did did not have
the capacity to absorb these millions,
tens of millions of refugees. But Angela
Merkel, the German chancellor, said, "We
can do this." Okay? And it's been a
dumpster fire for Europe. [snorts] All
right? You're talking about like civil
war possibly emerging in Europe over the
next 5 to 10 years.
>> You look at what's happened in Britain,
in France. Their populations are being
replaced.
>> Um, you know, and and and and I'm not
saying this is I'm not saying, you know,
refugees are bad. What I'm saying is
that nations need to protect their own
identity and our system because that's
what gives meaning and purpose to the
local population.
>> Yeah.
>> I I don't understand why people are
allowed to immigrate where wherever you
know we like like like it's it's absurd
to me where you know I'm from Canada and
there are a lot of Canadians who hate
the liberal government of Canada because
they're very authoritarian and I I'm I'm
one of them. Okay. But you just like you
just shouldn't be able to like pack your
bags and then move to America or Dubai
or Singapore. You should you should have
to stay where you are and fight for your
community because that's that's that's
what we that's what we've done
throughout human history. Like like like
if we always had the option of like just
like if we're unhappy just moving
somewhere else, we would never have
human civilization. Humanization is a
coming together of people with a common
bond with a common sense of identity and
then building on top of that. Right? So,
so I mean I I feel um we've gone too far
and we've embraced uh I mean like the
the the the very common phrase now very
popular phrase is suicidal empathy,
right?
>> Where you care too much about your
neighbor and when and when you when you
should really be looking after your own
house. Yeah, that is uh that's an idea
that's gaining a lot of traction here in
the US as we all think through how
exactly do we deal with this problem. Um
[clears throat] the thing that I've been
trying to convince my audience of is
that um values matter. And so a lot of
people are getting tangled up in this
concept as if it were a race issue. It's
not a race issue. When you find somebody
that say shares your religion, but
they're a completely different race than
you, you're far more bonded over the
fact that you share a religion than you
are alienated that they don't look like
you. And for some reason, especially
here in the West, we have just told the
story over and over and over that
everything comes down to your skin
color. But I just refuse to believe that
that's the experience people are
actually having. Uh it comes down to do
you click with somebody? Do you guys
view the world the same way? Do you
enjoy each other's company? And if you
look exactly like me, but I can't stand
to be around you. I don't have any sense
of affinity towards you whatsoever. Uh
so yeah, that one's very strange to me.
Now speaking of that, as you were talk,
sorry, go ahead.
>> I feel I I want to jump in here because
this very important point where
>> DEI multiculturalism, it's being used
used to justify the bureaucratization of
society. Right? So this is not so
apparent in America but if you go to
Europe and Canada it's really apparent
where these nations are essentially
authoritarian where if you say anything
now uh the police can come knock on your
door right so you go you go to England
where you know if you are part of these
like grooming gangs well the police
don't come after you but like if you
post about grooming gangs they'll come
knock on your door right and so France
Kathka writes about this in his book the
trial where bureaucrats don't bother
with criminals because it's a pain in
the ass. So they go after ordinary
citizens because ordinary citizens are
compliant and it allows them to feel
good about themselves and to you know
collect their paycheck. So that's what
we're seeing throughout the western
world, not in America, but in Canada, in
and and in Europe, where you have the
rise of this bureaucratic overclass that
justifies its existence by virtually
signaling, right, by by stopping on on
people who who want a sense of community
and identity.
>> Yeah. No, it's well said and it's wild
that uh Kofka was writing about this. It
just shows you that and some of the
stuff Orwell was doing. These are just
baked into the human psyche and so they
repeat over and over because these guys
are writing from 80 years ago. I mean
this is not like recent stuff. This was
very predictive a long time ago. Um
speaking of predictive, so part of what
has made you so famous is that you made
these predictions uh a couple years ago
that Trump was going to get elected.
this is before 20 the 24 election that
we would go to war with Iran and that we
would lose the war with Iran. Now,
there's a key part of your thesis that
we haven't touched on as to why all of
this plays out that we teased at the
beginning and I think we should pull
into Center Light now, which is the
religion of it all. So, um one you you
talk about esquetology, which I had
never heard before, uh so I had to look
that up. Uh so if you would it given
that it's basically religion but in the
extreme walk people through what
esquetology is why you use that word
instead of just saying religion and then
why you think right
>> that you're we're never going to
understand what's playing out right now
unless we understand that
>> right so esquetology comes from the
Greek word escaton which means the end
so esquetology literally means a study
of the uh end times uh but what it
really means is your understanding
of how the world ends or how uh humans
can become unified with God. Um and
different religions have different
esquetologies.
Um so that that's the word esquetology
and as you point out um it's usually
extremists who embrace uh esquetology.
But the problem with esquetology is that
it's very very powerful because as
humans there's always three questions
burning inside our hearts. The first
question is where do we come from?
Second question is what are we doing
here? The third question is where are we
going and esquetology answers all three
questions to the satis satisfaction of
the human heart. And so that's what
governizes energizes religious
extremists into action. If you look at
um esquetology
um the most passionate uh people right
now in America are people call Christian
Zionist. All right. So evangel
evangelicals are about a quarter of the
uh American population. And then among
the evangelicals, there are these very
passionate uh people who are only
minority. Okay? But they're Christian
Zionist. Um and the technical term for
them is premillennial dispensationalist.
And so what they believe is that the
world is theological, meaning that God
has divine plan that he voiced in the
Bible. So if you read the Bible
properly, it will tell you where the
world is going and how it will end. And
so what they believe is that um God has
a divine plan. If you have faith in God,
what you do is you accelerate the plan.
Okay? There's you cannot defy the will
of God. But what you can do is
accelerate his plan. And so these
Christians believe that Jesus will
return, but certain conditions have to
be met before Jesus can return. So the
first condition that needs to be met is
that Israel needs to be reconstituted as
a nation. Why? Because the Jews are
God's chosen people and God has a
covenant with the Jews which is um the
um land of Israel that God promised
Abraham their their ancestor. Okay. So
that's the first condition that needs to
be met. Second condition that needs to
be met is um the Jews need to build
Solomon's temple, the third temple. Um
and then the Jewish diaspora have to
return to Israel. They all have to
return. Okay? You can't be living in the
United States. You have to go back to
Israel. Um and then uh there has to be a
war of Gog and Mog. Um and then the
Antichrist will emerge to lead the the
Jews. Um to threaten to threaten the
Jews. Sorry.
return to
>> sorry yeah sorry so it's very confusing
because these esquetologists have
different details okay but then uh when
the antichrist um is most threatening
the existence of Israel
then Jesus will return to save the Jews
and when he returns Christians will be
rupture sorry raptured up into heaven
okay so you're a Christian you really
believe in Jesus uh when he returns
you're going directly to heaven
But if you're not a Christian, um then
you're going to suffer um
then Jesus will insue something called
the millennium, a thousand years of
eternal peace. Uh where Jesus rules the
world and at the end of the millennium
is the day of judgment where um he will
judge you a good person or a bad person.
If you're a good person, you live
forever. You're a bad person, you'll
burn in hell forever. Okay. So, so
that's what these Christians believe.
It's a very simplified version um uh
version, but as you can see, it's a very
compelling story of what you should be
doing of of how you can accelerate uh
the coming of heaven onto onto earth.
And unfortunately, these Christian
Zionists are embedded in the very fabric
of American political life. So, I'll
give an example where Peter Hex is is a
Christian Zionist. Um he um if you just
he has these um crusader tattoos um on
his body. He's talked about rebuilding
the third temple. Okay. Why that's an
issue is um the site where they want to
build the third temple is where the alax
mosque is. So you need you would need to
destroy the alex mosque first in order
to build a third temple. So the alexic
mosque is the third holiest site in the
uh Islamic world. Only Mecca and Medina
are more holy. And the Alex Mos is
apparently where um um Muhammad ascend
to uh heaven. Um and and for the longest
time, Alex Mos was actually controlled
by Jordan. Um and so only um um Muslims
are allowed actually in the Alex mosque.
But what's been happening these past few
days is that uh the Israelis have shut
off access to the Isaac mosque. And
there are rumors that um that the
Israelis might do a control demolition
of Alex Mos and blame it on the
Iranians.
>> Yeah. And uh that strikes me as a
terrible idea in that it will be one
immediately people will just assume that
they did it and then two that that will
galvanize the Muslim world against
>> uh Israel in a way that has never
happened before. Um what do you think
will happen if they destroy the mosque?
>> It's all been planned out where
destroying a mosque is very important
because as you point out it will
galvanize the entire Muslim world
against the uh Israelis and two and this
is really important is that you will see
a surge of anti-semitism throughout the
world where everyone sees the Israelis
as crazy fanatics and the Jews as en
enabling the uh u the Israelis. Okay.
But it's all part of their plan because
remember for their plan to work out
first of all all Jews need to return to
Jerusalem. Um and there has to be a war
of Gog and Magog where the entire world
unifies and attacks Israel. Okay. So
there mosque accomplishes both um
objectives.
And um yeah I mean I know it sounds
crazy. So so I so so so go ahead and ask
some questions. Well, so the big thing
is um how much credibility do you put in
that this is really a driver that these
different esquetologies and um there's
more to talk about but I think rather
than detail out each of the different
esquetologies just to know this idea
you've got uh Christian Zionists believe
one thing that's driving them to make
decisions at the nation state level that
may have had some influence in us going
into the area may have some influence in
whether we uh are allies with Israel or
not. Then you've got extremists within
Israel that believe in things like the
greater Israel theory and they want to
take over more land and they want to
actually piss people off and they want
this war of Gog and Magog which would be
great if you because there there's a
theory about who what current nation
states are Gog Magog and they're both in
play right now and so um understanding
that would be useful and then like
people will at least have the package
from which to understand where we'll go
from here. But understanding um whether
you think this is a primary driver,
whether you think this is just a fringe
theory and how much of this you actually
think has predictive validity.
>> When I do predictive modeling, I'm
looking at different theories and when
these different theories converge
together, um I can make a pretty
accurate prediction. Okay, so um there
are three major theories that I look at
when I make when when I make
predictions. The first theory is game
theory, which is I just look at the
different interests of the different
nation states. Okay, that's that's game
theory. Then I I look at historical
patterns, which is like how do empires
behave as they decline? Um, and so I I I
look at Rome, I look at um the British
Empire, I I look at different historical
uh instances of empires in decline. The
third thing is I look at esquetology. I
look at religion. Um and why
esquetomology is important is that it's
a script for um people to follow over
the centuries and they can slowly build
towards this uh script. Okay. So um when
I do these three things when I look at
esquetology when I look at dem theory
and when I look at historical patterns
then I'm forced to conclude that um they
will eventually destroy the Alexic
mosque and force the war of gamma. Okay.
So um first of all what I'm going to do
is explain to you how in your minds how
historical events should unfold. Okay?
How these current events should unfold
and then I'll explain to you the
religious rationale for why this should
happen. Okay? All right. So in the minds
of these um religious extremists and
they're Jewish and Christian um they
want uh this war in the Middle East to
destroy both Iran and the United States.
Okay. Basically they want the United
States sending ground troops to Iran. It
becomes another Vietnam. It is extremely
unpopular in America. There's a natural
draft. There's a civil war in America.
And now America is forced to retreat
from the Middle East. This is important
because America is not actually part of
this esquetology. And so how do you get
rid of the American empire? Well, you
cause civil war back in America. Okay,
that's that's number one. Number two is
that once Iran is destroyed,
um the Israel is able to achieve the
greater Israel project because there's
no there's no longer any uh local
opposition towards um Israel. So
remember like by this time the GCC
nations are also destroyed right because
of this war. So Israel is now very
quickly able to achieve the um greater
Israel project and build something
called a pjuda which is basically an AI
state um um and so it's basically what
they did in Gaza these past 10 years and
then scaling out across the um Middle
East. And so what they're going to do is
they're going to um allow transnational
capital to come in and build up their AI
AI infrastructure and they're going to
import millions of laborers from India,
China and the Philippines to work um uh
their their system and Paka will become
the main trading block for the world
because if you are Russian, if you're
Russian, you want to access African the
African market, you have to do you have
to go through Paka the greater greater
Israel uh just because of how trade
routes are are are established. Um and
then um greater Israel is then able to
export its surveillance technology
throughout the world and help other
nations build up their surveillance
networks. Okay. Um but then um because
Israel has destroyed the Alex mosque and
built their Solomon's temple, the third
temple, this galvanizes the Muslim
populations to rebel against the
governments because the government is
actually very pro- western, right? So uh
this creates this religious jihad fever
among um uh Muslim extremists and so you
see a reordering of the uh Muslim world
where governments are overthrown uh very
much like the um uh Arab Spring um and
and and and so and now what's going to
happen is like uh the Muslim world is
going to unify eventually against uh uh
and and join an alliance of Russia and
Iran. Okay. So by this time Iran will
will have rebuilt itself and then Russia
uh will um uh of the orthodox world will
form alliance with the ethnic world and
they will march against Israel and this
is called the war of G and Mog. Okay.
And then of course this will lead to the
end of the world uh where nuclear
weapons might be used. Um so that's how
they perceive historical events playing
out. Okay. Does that make sense?
>> It's all very clear. There's an internal
logic. The um the only thing that I'm
trying to pin down is you've got three
things. Are they sort of equal value or
do you think that one is bigger than the
other? Because the esquetology part is
where certainly my mental map is, yeah,
these guys are on the fringes. Yes,
there's like they can get their own base
riled up, but in a world that is
governed far more by economics than it
is by religious purity or enthusiasm,
um I don't expect that to be the primary
driver. And a very weird set of events
would have to trigger to get enough
people to believe that I'm really try
like I'm actually trying to bring back
God. um that it just seems like that
part has the it gives a nice flavor to
the whole thing, but it would be the
lowest in predictive validity. So, I'm
very curious if you think that has equal
predictive validity to the other two
things you walked us through, game
theory, historical precedent. Is this
like an equal third player or is this
like a well just by way of mentioning
everything, let me throw it in. So um
let me try to explain this slowly um
because it's actually very complicated.
Okay. All right. We first have to ask
where does this esquetology actually
come from. And what I think is that when
whenever you have prophecy it's probably
a lost historical memory meaning like
the prophecy that they have is something
that historically happened before in the
past but we've lost the memory of it.
And if you look at history and you try
to rec reconstruct history,
this prophecy, this esquetology, where
would it come from? And um the um and I
I think it would come from the rise of
Islam. And this happened in the 7th
century. All right. So what's happening
is like Persia and Rome are at war with
with each other. The the Romans are
called the Bison Empire. Okay? So you
have two major powers. the Persians uh
and the Bian Empire are at war with with
each other and they're fighting over uh
Jerusalem. Why they're fighting over
Jerusalem? Because Jerusalem is a major
uh trading nexus and if you control
Jerusalem, you're able to control Egypt.
And Egypt historically has been um the
main uh agricultural nation in the uh
Middle East. And at this time, uh, the
Jews
were very much trying to reestablish,
um, themselves back in Jerusalem because
they they've been expelled from
Jerusalem by by the Romans. And so they
went to the Persians for help. and they
convinced the Persians to come in and
and um at first it succeeded but then
the Bantine struck back and retook
Jerusalem and slaughtered a lot of um
and of of Jews. So under threat they
escaped into the Arabian desert and Jews
have been in the Arabian desert for a
long time and then they anointed their
messiah a man named Muhammad. Okay. And
this Muhammad created
which is this this um grand alliance
among believers. Okay. So his followers
were going to call believers and then
they march to um uh march against both
the Persians and the Bisantines. And
they were very quickly able to overwhelm
uh both the Persian and the Bison. Why?
Because by this time both of these
empires have been exhausted through
years and years of war. And in fact
there was civil conflict within their
nations as well. And so they off they
really didn't offer that much resistance
against a galvanized uh army of
religious fanatics. Okay. And so uh um
they were able then to establish the
caliphate. All right. Uh which was this
grand alliance between Christians, Jews
and uh and Muslims. And we've lost this
memory because um these because those
who succeeded this caliphate had
invested interest in discussing the fact
that um there's a revolution happening,
right? Because now they're an empire. So
they they want to disguise the
revolution. Okay. So so so is is this is
this make any sense to you so far? Are
are are you
>> It does. And I'm reading between the
lines though because really what I'm
trying to establish is I'm sure you're
aware this is the part of your thesis
that people are going to lean on and say
that's all crazy. That's conspiracy
theory. You're applying way too much to
this. So I'm just trying I I think you
think this is a pretty major part of the
predictive um recipe and that if you
fail to understand that this religious
esquetology is actually tied to
historical events. So it's historical
events said in a religious allegorical
way. Um then you're really missing
something important. So that answered my
question in terms of uh I think you
believe that it has predictive validity
and that people are getting lost in the
religion of it all instead of realizing
that this is just another way of saying
this is how things have played out
historically. Um so yeah, it it answers
my question assuming that that was an
accurate representation of what you just
said.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, sure. Um, so something
to keep in mind is like for most of
human history, we've kept um history,
the lessons of history using
allegorories, right? Using stories
because we we didn't have writing uh you
didn't actually write stuff down. You
actually told stories and and by telling
stories you make you have to make them
much more imaginative. Okay. So I think
estology is actually just lost
historical memories of patterns that
emerge uh through time. The reason why
uh these religions are so powerful is
that they have access to thousands and
thousands year thousands of years of
human history, right? Which they
condense into um patterns that then they
relay on to their followers. Yeah. So
know another thing of saying this is
that like game theory, historical
patterns and esquetology are actually
aligned together and and that's why
they're so powerful together.
>> Dr. Jang, uh this time has been
absolutely incredible. I cannot thank
you enough for taking the time to do it.
And then also just your uh meteoric rise
I think is extraordinarily justified.
You've got such a unique take on this.
Obviously very deep, very broad in terms
of your background in poetry and things
that um just give you such a different
lens on this. Where can people follow
along with you online? Yeah. So there
are two ways um to follow me online and
the first the best way is uh through my
YouTube channel predictive history and
then I have a Substack uh which actually
goes deep and analyzes um geopolitical
events to give you insight into how
things should progress and it it's a
predictive history.substack.com.
>> I love it. Awesome man. Thank you again
for taking the time and everybody at
home if you have not already be sure to
subscribe and I will see you next time
my friends. Take care. Be legendary.
Peace. If you like this conversation,
check out this episode to learn more.
Never has there been a crazier time.
This is absolutely wild. The uh Iranian
war has kicked off. It is, I think,
full-fledged at this point. Now, I think
a lot of people are getting the analysis
on Iran wrong. They either get sucked
into the